I bet you gonna shine that scene in rush
hour but the people come out to Jackie
Chan they're like been the Roscoe's
chicken and waffles
I've never been there I usually like
chicken to be spicy I don't know how I
feel about waffles with it you know it
just seems wrong
I just know of it as this magical la
thing that is that Roscoe's how have you
never tried taking a walk I mean I'm
gonna chalk it up to like having white
parents and being from the Midwest I see
it as like a rite of passage though as a
black person I'm from Mexico so it's not
a thing in Mexico - we have waffles and
we have a chicken of course that is not
a thing to mix them both
I just expect magic to happen in my
mouth I expect it to be sweet I guess
which is not something I necessarily
want from chicken I need this right now
fancy a F oh my god pretty official all
right oh my god it looks like heaven on
a plate wonderful things okay okay
I feel unequipped to deal with this I'll
go it man all right let's try it oh my
god this is how I choose to eat this
hello mmm little chewy it's a lot all at
once my whole diet is really just makes
the chicken taste like a waffle am I
supposed to a hot sauce on it definitely
bad with the hot sauce no that's good
with the hot sauce I like it with the
hot sauce it's kind of taste like it was
meant to be this way I think I
understand
I wouldn't put salsa or these salsa
these are like lime
I never gone out seeking chicken and
waffles before but I damn well died damn
sure I'm so excited only God say [ __ ] a
woman that was pregnant wake up some day
and it's like I want waffles and fried
chicken with maple syrup and some hot
sauce all together I would say it tasted
like home but does it taste like my home
it tastes like someone else's home this
might be my new just launching at work I
got the hype now I mean when you go back
to that rush hour scene and you see
those people come on Jackie Chan and
like what's the rusco chicken and
waffles that I'll be like right here
she's right dose three in the corner
it's just so sad what's happening over
there oh yeah you don't know the half of
it